[Musica]
siamo tutti abituati ormai a leggere la
postura del nostro interlocutore Quindi
quando ci troviamo di fronte a qualcuno
facciamo attenzione a come mettere le
gambe come tiene le braccia se ci sta
ascoltando Ma cosa succede se la postura
che ci interessa non è visibile riguarda
qualcosa di più sottile come il rapporto
con il futuro
polac ha ideato un gioco per permetterci
di
collocarci identificare il nostro il
nostro approccio è un sociologo di
origine ebrea rifugiato nei Paesi Bassi
che nel secondo dopoguerra scrive un
importante libro dal nome l'immagine del
futuro
Per questo io vi chiederei stasera di
giocare con me per identificare la
vostra postura nei confronti del futuro
vi farò due semplici domande a cui vi
chiedo di rispondere la prima riguarda
le vostre aspettative nei confronti del
2101 rispetto al tema della Giustizia
climatica e della migrazione quindi a
seconda che siate ottimisti o pessimisti
nei confronti di come andranno le cose
Vi chiederò di alzare la mano quando
darò indicazioni a riguardo quindi
chiederei ora a tutte le persone
ottimiste rispetto a come andranno le
cose da qua al 21001 rispetto alla
giustizia climatica e la migrazione di
alzare la mano
Grazie mille e ora è il turno dei
pessimisti
Chissà perché Lo sospettavo Eh ragazzi
la seconda questa prima domanda ci
permette di collocarci sui quadranti che
vedete qui dietro di me quindi gli
ottimisti si collocheranno nei due
quadranti in alto in verde e invece i
pessimisti nei due quadrati blu in basso
la seconda domanda riguarda invece il
livello di azione che sentite di avere
rispetto alla possibilità di azione
quindi che cosa sentite di poter fare
quanto sentite di poter contribuire un
cambiamento in questo caso vi invito a
immaginare di avere un barometro davanti
a voi dove lo zero coincide con le
vostre gambe e 10 il punto più alto che
è riuscito a toccare con la vostra mano
userete la mano di taglio e quindi Zero
sarai il punto più basso 5 da parte
mediana e 10 quella più alta Quindi
votate adesso rispetto a quanto sentite
di poter incidere sulla su come andranno
le cose per la giustizia climatica e la
migrazione da qui al 21
qua cambiano già un po' le cosine
in questo caso dico collocherete a
sinistra se avete sentito di avere un
livello di agency che va da 0 a 5 e
nella parte destra invece se vi
collocate tra il 5 e il 10
polac ha identificato così quattro
possibili posture nei confronti del
futuro Quindi potrete sentirvi potenti
capaci di incidere significativamente
sull'andamento di qualcosa volto al
miglioramento oppure a servizio capaci
di supportare un miglioramento ma non
protagonisti in alternativa
consapevoli che tutto andrà come deve
andare che non avete nessuno spazio di
manovra su questo vi sentirete liberi
oppure stoici pronti a combattere per
qualcosa che sapete non volto al
miglioramento
è importante iniziare a prendere
dimestichezza con una visione di futuro
collocarsi capire che cosa si osserva
perché cambia il modo in cui potremo
agire Naturalmente se io vi chiedessi
adesso di disegnare il futuro sareste
portati a immaginare una linea retta che
va dal presente verso un tempo
determinato non come posizione
lavorativa Naturalmente per cui
Che cosa succede se invece cambiamo
approccio e il futuro diventa uno spazio
di possibilità il cui perimetro più
esteso è dato dalla nostra immaginazione
perché mentre noi stiamo discutendo il
futuro non esiste vorrei ricordarvi
questo aspetto è qualcosa che possiamo
immaginare non produce evidenze il
perimetro più esteso è dato da quello
che viene detto futuro assurdo Quindi
utopie di stupire più e coraggiosa e
dirompente la nostra immaginazione e più
ci renderemo conto che il futuro è
diverso dal presente mentre Oggi siamo
portati a schiacciarlo verso quello che
abbiamo esperito fino ad ora a non
pensare che le cose possano essere
significativamente diverse
dentro questo perimetro esteso trovate i
futuri possibili Quindi quelli che sono
in linea con il nostro principio di
realtà ma che riguardano delle
conoscenze che ancora non abbiamo che
possono essere eventi che trasformano
anche in maniera radicale ciò che
conosciamo oppure conoscenze nuove in
ambito tecnologico sociale politico
stringendo ancora il nostro fuoco
andando a mettere meglio a fuoco la
nostra immagine dei futuri troveremo
futuri plausibili Quindi quelli che sono
in linea con il nostro principio di
realtà che riguardano quello che
conosciamo e che riteniamo possano
accadere
questo perimetro ci offre uno spazio
ancora più puntuale che sono i futuri
probabili quei futuri che sono
il frutto delle esperienze che abbiamo
già fatto nel passato delle tendenze che
abbiamo visto accadere e che promettono
di continuare a evolvere in una
direzione Chiara su questi si basano i
futuri progettati le strategie i piani
d'azione aziendali gli accordi che tra
esseri umani stiamo facendo per cercare
di costruire un futuro diverso ma che
non tengono in alcuna considerazione una
serie di variabili una guerra mondiale
una pandemia Diciamo che su questo
l'immaginazione sta iniziando ad
attivarsi perché abbiamo diversi spunti
da dalla realtà
Ora però è importante che prendiamo
coscienza di come fra tutti questi
futuri di cui abbiamo discusso di cui
alcuni sono davvero poco auspicabili
esistano dei futuri da desiderare che
attivino nella civiltà un'immagine verso
cui tendere che muova nuove energie ed
esattamente quello di cui parla polac
nel suo libro
giustizia climatica e migrazione fanno
parte di questa immagine è davvero
importante che prendiamo coscienza che
come genere umano in questo momento
dobbiamo disegnare un futuro che possa
garantire a tutti uguali diritti
Considerando che eventi avversi ehm
nuovi costi andranno a incidere su
condizioni molto diverse che possono
essere dettate da genere appartenenza
sociale un territorio di provenienza e
che cambierà radicalmente l'immagine
dell'umanità per cui ci troveremo a
vivere in città che si apriranno Ah
abitanti temporanei o meno e Quindi
dovremo mettere in discussione il modo
in cui costruiamo la nostra cultura
perché possa trarre vantaggio dallo
scambio con altri
prima guardavamo un orizzonte temporale
non definito c'è qualcuno che ci dice
che il tempo a nostra disposizione non è
tantissimo e Setta lo spazio a 80 anni
Questa è un'immagine con cui abbiamo
iniziato a prendere dimestichezza è
stata prodotta dal Panel intergoverna
mentale per il cambiamento climatico
offre quattro scenari differenti e ci
mostra che da qui a circa 80 anni le
cose potrebbero essere
significativamente differenti in
funzione delle azioni che andremo a
mettere in campo vedete la linea rossa
in continuità con quella nera che ci
racconta Che cosa accade Se continuiamo
con un'emissione di gas uguale a quella
del passato con un meccanismo di
produzione che non cambia raggiungeremo
delle temperature che aumenteranno dai 5
ai 7 gradi rendendo inabitabile la terra
per la maggioranza degli esseri umani
C'è invece un obiettivo che ci stiamo
dando che di avere un innalzamento non
superiore al 1,5 1,8 gradi centigradi
questo cambia Comunque i meccanismi di
funzionamento della nostra terra Quindi
eventi climatici improvvisi e
significativi secche come quella del Po
che abbiamo visto in questi giorni ci
chiedono di riorganizzarci ma sono
più e quindi ci permettono di muoverci
in maniera diversa
al momento quando raffiguriamo i nostri
sistemi sono sistemi socio tecnici che
portano al centro la produzione e che
quindi vanno a tracciare relazioni con
tendenzialmente i clienti
certo linee di produzione ma il nostro
Focus per ora è stato quello di produrre
e consumare Cosa succede se invece
iniziamo a ragionare come ecosistema
dove tutti siamo chiamati a collaborare
per costruire una visione differente
mettendo a disposizione le nostre
migliori conoscenze per attuare una
trasformazione dove tra gli attori da
tenere in considerazione ci sono anche
le Risorse naturali che devono essere
rigenerate per continuare ad alimentare
le generazioni che verranno come la
nostra Costituzione impone da poco tempo
vedete Questo è il multilevel perfective
racconta il modo in cui i sistemi socio
tecnici si costituiscono
ci dimostrano che si organizzano in
funzione delle evoluzioni delle
pressioni del sistema esterno esterno
pandemie carestie
opportunità anche di trasformazione che
costringono i nostri regimi cioè il modo
in cui la nostra società si organizza ha
una trasformazione a una modifica che
deve dialogare con le innovazione a
disposizione le nicchie ciò che al
momento accade in laboratorio o in
piccoli contesti
queste nicchie devono essere guidate
verso una trasformazione perché se non
sono orientate non andranno verso la
visione che noi auspichiamo basta
pensare alle tecnologie alle
intelligenze artificiali devono essere
allenate dagli umani per rispondere ad
una visione che garantisca l'equità ad
esempio
abbiamo degli strumenti per progettare
tutto ciò è ovvio che una cultura Non
può essere progettata per intero Ci sono
diversi elementi che ci chiedono di
rimanere in ascolto delle trasformazioni
Anche perché non conosciamo tutto del
futuro Ma alcuni elementi possono essere
costruiti e abbiamo dei framework dei
sistemi che raccolgono un certo tipo di
mindset cioè il modo in cui ragioniamo
degli strumenti di facilitazione quindi
degli spazi in cui i ragionamenti
possano essere costruiti insieme e delle
fasi dei meccanismi che ci permettono di
collaborare di facilitare il dialogo
anche tra settori che portano linguaggi
modi di pensare e di agire differenti
tra i diversi paradigmi che questi spazi
di riflessione ci offrono c'è il tre
orizzonti che vedete proiettato alle mie
spalle e semplicemente una matrice che
si muove su due assi da una parte il
tempo che abbiamo capito essere
importante e dall'altra invece la
rispondenza strategica delle azioni che
mettiamo in atto rispetto al contesto in
cui operiamo
vediamo questi disegnarsi una prima
curva che rappresenta il meccanismo di
funzionamento del regime attuale del
modo in cui la nostra società si
organizza oggi e che inizia e lo so la
reazione è sempre questa il fatto di un
regime che va in decadimento porta al
pianto è proprio qualcosa di drammatico
perché è un cambiamento piuttosto
significativo naturalmente Però vorrei
rassicurare Grazie
[Applauso]
vorrei rassicurare il pubblico Non tutto
si disperde quello che abbiamo costruito
si va ad assestare in una nicchia Futura
dobbiamo imparare a rigenerare quello
che abbiamo costruito senza dover per
forza Cancellare tutto
vediamo scendere così un nuovo modo per
questo innovazione trasformativa
qualcosa che va a ridisegnare tutto e
che ha origine nel presente perché la
buona notizia che ci arriva dal
dall'ultimo report del governo del
gruppo di lavoro intergoverna mentale
perché il cambiamento climatico la sigla
è orribile Quindi è meglio dirlo sempre
per intero ma diventa uno scioglilingua
e che abbiamo a disposizione tutte le
tecnologie che ci servono per attuare la
trasformazione che ci permetterebbe di
stare sotto
l'1,5°c e quindi continuare a vivere
come terrestre
naturalmente questo richiede un
accompagnamento come vedevamo prima per
ridisegnare il sistema
per riuscire a costruire una
trasformazione così significativa serve
una strategia va accompagnato tutto ciò
Per questo si parla di transizione
io mi occupo di facilitare la
cooperazione Tra trattori differenti e
ho evoluto questo paradigma nella mia
pratica andando a occuparmi nel modo
specifico della transizione qui vedete
dei passaggi che ho costruito per
permettere a sistemi complessi di
ragionare sulle azioni da mettere in
campo nella costruzione di strategie
innovative per trovare i punti
strategici e identificare le azioni
prioritarie perché quando allunghi lo
sguardo cambia ciò che urge ti rendi
conto che hai uno spazio di azione
differente vedete quindi che il primo
passaggio è la costruzione di una
visione condivisa che abbia una serie di
parametri tra cui l'equità il secondo è
l'identificazione diagnostica delle
obsolescenze che cosa non funziona più
rispetto all'evoluzione del nostro
sistema
questo ci permette di andare
identificare quelli che potremmo
definire i semi di futuro Quindi quelle
nuove pratiche quelle innovazioni che
già a partire dal presente ci permettono
di raggiungere la nostra visione di
costruirla quarto passaggio
l'identificazione dell'eredità dal
presente che cosa nel passare del tempo
deve essere custodito perché diventerà
ciò da rigenerare per le nuove
generazioni quella base di innovazione
per quello che verrà perché la sfida non
si ferma Fra Cioè 201 anni
continuerà a chiederci di cambiare di
trasformarci Poi è ovvio Tutte le specie
si estinguono quindi chi lo sa però nel
frattempo facciamolo con intelligenza
questo ci permette di andare a
identificare il quinto passaggio le
resistenze il sistema inobscrescenza
cercherà di schiacciare il nicchie non è
facile cambiare Ci sono degli interessi
ovviamente che cercano di trattenere il
cambiamento dal Green washing o tutto
quello che vi viene in mente e bisogna
esserne consapevoli
l'altro passaggio fondamentale
identificato qui come passaggio sei sono
le derive le pratiche che funzionano in
contesti ridotti nel loro skill up nella
loro crescita potrebbero distorcersi
potrebbero allontanarsi dalla nostra
visione e allo stesso modo quelle
risorse che Dovranno diventare l'eredità
del presente devono essere accompagnate
Perché i sistemi obsolescenza lascia dei
detriti che se non vengono usati nel
modo corretto rischiano di non poter
essere delle risorse vedo la signora
particolarmente preoccupata ma Le
garantisco che c'è lieto fine eh
infatti la regione Emilia Romagna ad
esempio grazie alla sua partecipata
arter ha sviluppato un percorso
all'interno di un progetto europeo che
si chiama territorio di futurizzazione
come si lascia aperto il futuro per
collezionare risorse economiche anche da
finanziamenti europei per poter attuare
delle strategie nuove che coinvolgano
attori differenti
Nel nostro caso abbiamo scelto come
prioritario il settore del benessere
della salute e la cosa più incredibile
che è accaduta e che nonostante la
giustizia ambientale non fosse tra i
temi che dovevamo trattare è stato
naturale costruire una visione che lo
prevedesse andando a stratificare la
visione chi vive in condizioni di
difficoltà economica ovviamente
farà più fatica e va gestito in maniera
differente va accompagnato
quindi siamo partiti da un documento
strategico perché ovviamente ci sono le
Policy di cui parlavamo prima e abbiamo
ragionato su scala regionale Nazionale
Europea
Abbiamo costruito tre passaggi il primo
ha permesso di costruire memorie
collettive di futuri possibili quindi
maturare una visione reale di futuro il
secondo passaggio è stato andare a
costruire la visione verso cui tendere e
i meccanismi di transizione e l'ultima
costituita un lavoro di Policy design
che ha permesso di capire come costruire
dei nuovi bandi che permettessero di
lasciare aperto il futuro
quindi il mio invito stasera è cambiare
postura verso il futuro
riappropiandosene rendendosi conto che è
qualcosa di comune condiviso necessario
per essere pronti a trasformarsi insieme
perché il nostro futuro comune come si
chiamava il primo documento in cui
appare il termine sostenibilità e in
realtà il nostro presente comune
Grazie a tutti